how do we find 33 squared 33 is neither
close to 10 not close to 100 in short
it's not close to any power of 10 but we
know that 33 is close to 30 and 10 times
3 is equal to 30 so we have chosen 30 as
the reference here because 33 is close
to 30 30 is a multiple of a power of 10
here we say that 10 is the base and 30
is the working base the working base
here is the third multiple of 10 once
we're done finding the base and the
working base we find the difference
between the number and the working base
that will be 33 minus 30 which equals 3
once we find the base working base and
the difference we make a partition on
the left we write the sum of the number
and this difference that will be 30 3
plus 3 and on the right we square the
difference 3 squared the number of
digits we should write on the right of
the partition is equal to the number of
zeros in the base as we have just one
zero in the base we write just one digit
on the right so the steps we have seen
until now are pretty similar to the ones
we saw for the multiples of ten find the
working base the difference between the
number and the working base make a
partition write the sum of the number
and this difference on the left and then
write the square of the difference on
the right there is one major difference
though the answer will not be 369 what
else do we need to do here then yes the
difference here is that once we complete
these four steps we have to multiply the
left hand side with three yes this then
tire thing with 333 plus 3 is 36 and 36
times 3 is 108 and three squared is nine
thirty three squared is 1089 the steps
were more or less the same as the ones
we had seen for squaring numbers close
to the power of 10 the major difference
was this part where we multiplied the
left hand side with three let's look at
the next one 82 squared
82 is not close to any power of 10 it is
close to 80 which
a multiple of a power of 10 we know that
10 times 8 is equal to 80 10 is the base
and 80 is the working base why don't you
try this one on your own
try arriving at the correct answer by
referring to the solution on the left in
the next step we find the difference
between the number and the working base
that will be 82 minus 80 which is equal
to 2 after this step we make the
partition on the left we add the number
and this difference 82 plus 2 and on the
right we square the difference 2 squared
the number of digits on the right will
be equal to the number of zeros in the
base-10 one digit and don't forget the
most important step here to multiply the
left-hand side with 8 on the left we
will have 84 times 8 that equals 672 and
2 squared is 4 82 squared is 6 thousand
seven hundred and twenty-four we will
look at a couple of more examples in the
next part of the session but remember
the most important step here to multiply
the left side with this number other
than that the steps are similar to the
ones we follow for squaring numbers
close to a power of 10